this summer james schloss and i ran a
contest that's meant to encourage more
people to make online math explainers
and here i want to share with you some
of my favorites i wrote up a much fuller
blog post about the event and the
process for selecting winners but let's
open here with some of the key points
first of all it was extremely open-ended
it's meant for math explainers of any
kind any medium any target audience any
topic pretty much just as long as it's
about math
the promise was to select around four to
five to be winners which i would then
feature in a video here we are now and
after i made the initial announcement
brilliant came in and kindly offered
cash prizes to those winners now before
anything let me just emphasize this
notion of a winner should really be
taken with a heavy grain of salt the
spirit of the event and hopefully this
is obvious is to get more people sharing
their knowledge and preferably to have
them do so in a way that's as engaging
and empathetic and novel as possible the
way i see it there's some benefits to
framing it as a contest like we have a
clear deadline and that can be a great
cure for perfectionism and stagnation
also having some small stakes involved
hopefully means that the lessons are put
together with a little bit more care and
with a little bit more attention to the
kind of principles that i wanted to
emphasize with the whole event
the downside which is not to be taken
lightly is that it gives the false
impression that success looks like
winning but it does not success means
having more material out there that
explains math and inspires people to
engage with it ten years from now no one
is going to remember my arbitrary
selections but every one of the pieces
made will still exist and will still
potentially help someone trying to learn
we received over 1200 submissions and as
a first pass for the judgment we had a
peer review process to help filter that
down to a little over 100 that james and
i could give a really close look at we
also had around half a dozen guest
judges people in the space of math
exposition to help us narrow down those
final judgments many many thanks to
those guests for being willing to
volunteer some of their time and
generally helping to ensure that any of
my subjective quirks weren't leaking too
much into the final decision
also a million thanks to james he really
was the core organizer behind everything
here and if you participated in the
event and found it helpful he is
absolutely the one you should be
thanking
as i said there's a blog post with more
details for any of you who are curious
but right now without further ado let me
tell you about some outstanding math
explainers made this summer that i
really think you're going to enjoy
this entry from a channel called
perological opens by asking why the
light reflected at the bottom of a mug
seems to form this characteristic
cardioid shape
the core mathematical idea that this
video teaches is that of envelopes which
in short is a way to describe one curve
using a family of other curves and what
really makes the video special is not
just how clearly he explains that
subject but how tangible and well-chosen
the examples are all delivered with a
tone that's just plain friendly and
enjoyable to listen to
the key formula he builds up to is
really well motivated and one of those
things that would not be obvious if you
just saw it out of context and he gives
the tools for any curious viewer to
pause and work through for themselves a
more detailed understanding while still
leaving room for someone watching to get
the general idea and the core points
without necessarily being bogged down
into that algebra
on the topic of fun ways that light gets
redirected another one of my picks is
just an absolutely mind-blowing piece of
engineering wizardry this one is a blog
post it's written by matt ferraro where
he explains how he made this acrylic
square it might look innocent at first
like nothing more than a transparent
square may be suspiciously wavy but when
you look at its shadow you can see that
it's been carefully crafted to redirect
light in such a way as to form a highly
deliberate image
the post walks through all of the math
and the algorithms involved in pulling
this off
including certain false starts in the
discovery process which i love and the
author skillfully draws the reader's
attention to which details are important
and deserve more of your focus and which
ones are more side notes and minutiae
i found myself a little surprised about
what parts of the process turned out to
be hard and which ones were easy and by
the end the whole task felt a lot less
mysterious while still commanding no
shortage of respect for the fact that
someone was actually able to pull it off
the next pick that i have on my list
here i'll be honest i felt a little bit
torn about i wouldn't be surprised if
many of you have already seen this video
it's called the beauty of bezier curves
by freya homer
now given the spirit of the contest
which is to encourage people to share
their knowledge without necessarily
getting intimidated by a need for high
production quality you know focus on the
quality of the lesson more so than the
medium used to express it this video was
so beautifully produced i almost felt
like choosing it risks sending the wrong
message also part of the goal here is to
shine a light on comparatively unknown
creators and by the time i was watching
this one it had around 400 000 views
but the thing is freyja's video really
is a fantastic piece of exposition and
it would be a little bit silly of me to
fault it for also being beautiful and
evidently also being appreciated by many
people in both respects
i do want to be clear the reason that
i'm choosing it is not because of the
smooth graphics it's that here we have
someone who uses a certain mathematical
tool regularly in her work and she has
the ability to clearly motivate why you
should care too and to go into the
details of how it works the many
different facets of how she uses it how
she thinks about it and what makes it
visually great is not so much the
smoothness of the graphics or the
aesthetic appeal it's that they're clean
and to the point serving to aid what's
the core value in the whole piece a
series of well-chosen intuitions and
applications of a topic in math that
deserves to be known by more people
after that one i really did think that
with my other picks i could help direct
the audience of this channel to some
excellent lessons that you might not
have seen yet like with the next one i
chose when i saw it it had a couple
hundred views and i really loved it and
i was excited to share it with you all
but then it looks like the internet kind
of beat me to it this thing is quickly
going on a million views well deserved
by the way
if you haven't seen it it really is
delightful it's not a traditional math
lesson in the sense of explaining some
topic that you might need to learn for a
course or even one that exists in a
clear field for that matter but it
absolutely captures the spirit of
mathematical discovery the question
posed in the video seems a little bit
silly at first which is what's the most
complicated passcode for those sorts of
swipey swipey pattern passcodes that
some phones have
the video opens by making that question
rigorous giving it a solid definition
and then proceeds with a really engaging
story of problem solving that involves
very real math lessons along the way
things about number theory about
induction about generalizing a result
even after you've solved a sub problem
definitely take a look
the final pick i have on my list here
which again is in no particular order is
one that multiple different guest judges
singled out as being especially good and
also easily underappreciated
the video describes a really clever and
memorable proof of this cute fact from
geometry known as pix theorem
and more than that the author has some
really nice thoughts about the role of
different kinds of proofs in math
thoughts which more students and for
that matter more teachers would really
benefit from hearing and thinking about
it's no fancier than it needs to be but
the core idea is just so good that to me
at least the video has a lot more
staying power than many of the
professionally produced educational
videos that i've seen from established
channels out there
so there you go those are my five picks
for this summer of math exposition
but the thing is if you had seen the
submissions that i have seen you would
agree that choosing just five winners is
ridiculous to the point of absurdity
again you know the point is not the
winners the event is about encouraging
people to follow through with projects
things about math exposition they might
have been thinking about doing all of
that
but just reiterating that point feels a
little bit hollow because there are at
least i don't know 20 in here where i
feel like it is a genuine crime not to
have chosen them
and well you know it's my contest my
rules so if you'll indulge me let me
quickly tell you about some others that
i just loved one that i think viewers of
this channel would especially enjoy is
almost an hour it's about derock's belt
trick by noah miller
in a recent event that i was doing with
steven strogatz for the mo math museum
we had a call that was ostensibly meant
to prepare for that event but instead we
spent much of it just both gushing over
how much we liked this one particular
video any of you who have flirted with
this topic will probably know how tricky
it can be to understand the link between
points on a 4d sphere and rotations in
3d space and why any of that has to do
with quantum mechanics but this animated
hour-long lecture does a really good job
laying out the full story
another one which is long but good is
about the unsolvability of the quintic
by carl turner for me it was a bit
bizarre seeing it because when i did i
was actively working on a video that was
not just about the same theorem but
about the same comparatively esoteric
proof that it describes there i thought
the video did such a wonderful job i
just kind of set aside the project i'll
still probably cover it at some point
but now i'm motivated to do it in a
different way but in the meantime any of
you curious about why quintic
polynomials are in a certain sense
unsolvable we'll absolutely love this
video
so many entries here were just really
solid explainers plain and simple this
includes the best overview i've seen of
the two envelope problem a great
explanation for how fonts get turned
into pixels a wonderful article on
spinners a comic style blog post about e
a video about an ancient babylonian
algorithm for multiplying numbers which
has unexpected usefulness for certain
programming tasks
there were a number of videos in chinese
on the site billy billy including one i
really liked about a fundamental theorem
for symmetric polynomials perfectly
understandable with the english
subtitles
and one absolutely fantastic video in
here was about lemur factor stencils
which i had never heard of and i learned
a ton watching this and found it
absolutely fascinating
many of the entries i saw had excellent
aha moments like this one here with a
mildly clickbaity title about a graph
that will blow your mind but the thing
is at least in my experience that title
is 100 accurate
there's a video explaining why pi shows
up in the buffon needle problem with a
really elegant shift in perspective and
what i especially appreciate is that the
author also has an appendix video going
through some of the more technical
details not covered in the main video a
few entries were highly interesting if
for no other reason just from a
technological standpoint alone including
a very well executed interactive video
by rob schlub which let me tell you is
not easy to pull off as well as a great
interactive article introducing complex
numbers and the fundamental theorem of
algebra on the site trina
and then some of the entries setting
aside all the explanatory value were
just plain beautiful like if i had a
category here for greatest style i think
my pick would be this one about
recreating curves from a children's toy
but setting aside style or the core
point of all of this which is the
explanatory quality there's one feature
of online explainers that can easily be
under-appreciated which is the role of
narrative and storylines and a couple
entries i think did a great job
exemplifying that component
this includes not one but two entries on
this game called hack and bush a story
about how a lights out puzzle can lead
you to gaussian elimination a nice
exploration of the most efficient way to
choose a random point in a circle
uniformly a great puzzle about tiles
which carries with it explanations of
core facts from fibonacci numbers and
one really nicely done video about why
the sierpinski triangle shows up in
three seemingly completely unrelated
contexts again the list goes on for
quite a while
as i look at some of these now i'm
really pleased to see that a lot of them
have picked up some traction on youtube
but there still remain many which are
very
underappreciated i highly encourage you
to go to the playlist including all the
video submissions and to check out the
blog post featuring all other
submissions
as you look at that playlist i would not
read into the order of it too much it
was generated programmatically but i did
try to go through and curate the first
few ones with videos that i think you
might especially like honestly though
you can happily scroll down that
playlist and find hidden gems all
throughout like really go check it out
right now if you do i can almost
guarantee that you have hours of
edification waiting ahead of you not to
mention hours of just pure delight
thanks again to everyone who
participated let me just say one more
time i really was blown away by the
quality here
[Music]
[Music]
you